[Musique]
menus plaisirs d'été un événement à
l'initiative du centre de musique
baroque de versailles
objectif faire découvrir le panel d'art
que représente la musique baroque et
scream chant danse théâtre
une dizaine d'artistes participent au
projet quand on crée un spectacle et un
opéra derrière il ya la machinerie donc
il ya des décors il ya des costumes
il ya des danseurs il ya des comédiens
chanteurs il ya des musiciens vous
faites c'est pour montrer que c'est pas
uniquement la musique et que derrière il
ya vraiment tout un tas de métiers et de
et d'artistes qui permettent de faire ce
spectacle
[Musique]
un spectacle humoristique et
participatif objectif faire découvrir et
rendre accessible la musique baroque
pour nous c'est important de de faire
des petites choses participatifs comme
ça et de prouver en fait que par le rire
marie réléguant à rire baroque qui est
qui et le rire du grand molière le
molière clics et sans doute de celui qui
nous fait le plus rire encore de montrer
qu'on peut participer et que
véritablement toutes les générations
peuvent accéder à ce répertoire
d'autres représentations auront lieu à
versailles particularité le spectacle
sera complétée par des ateliers décor
champs ou encore costumes l'idée rentrer
dans les coulisses d'un spectacle de
baroque les gens découvrent les ateliers
et ensuite à l'issue de ces ateliers là
il découvre le spectacle donc ils ont vu
un petit peu les différents acteurs qui
aura ensuite dans le spectacle après
deux jours à maurepas les menus plaisirs
d'été continue à la verrière pour un
spectacle en plein air et du 10 au 14
juillet au centre de musique baroque de
versailles